you
let's bring the hearing to uh
let's open the hearing
on
1665.
but before we do that we want you all
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
roll call uh
okay uh cheers dolan
here representative pierre monty here
uh the clerk's here
representative tripp
president
representative guthrie yeah
representative los alas
representative mcbride
representative melvin
representative
representative powell here
representative tray 11
representative gilman here
represent majority here
representative davis
representative megaputi
representative fan
representative klee here
representative gallagher
here
and representative wrong yeah
thank you
thank you everyone uh we we're gonna
have some uh
some substitutes today
uh and
they're not really due to be here
until we get into the the exec sessions
for sure 11
she'll be replaced by representative
long
representative manchapudi will be
replaced by representative perez
and representative stavis will be be
replaced by
representative
telersky
on the other side of the aisle
representative mcbride will be replaced
okay
[Music]
want to begin
okay the floor is yours
good morning chairman dolan and good
morning members of the municipal
committee
for the record my name is representative
judy aaron i represent sullivan county
district 7 representing the towns of
acworth goshen langdon lobster and
washington
i'm introducing this bill today and
asked and asked that you support hb
1665.
this bill came about after the july 29th
storm that hit our state and created
millions of dollars in damage to towns
in cheshire and sullivan county
specifically i'm here to talk about what
happened in my own little town of
acworth and how this bill
would have helped us tremendously
because of the july floods my town
suffered millions of dollars of road
damage bridge damage and crop damage
farmer fields were destroyed at the
start of harvest season
sap lines were damaged and hay was left
to rot in the fields
because our roads were badly damaged
farmers were unable to empty their
manure pits and mail could not be
delivered utility poles in danger of
falling over could not be reached to
repair them and we could not get
emergency vehicles through these roads
either
there was only one way in and out of our
town
and that road had been damaged as well
akworth had a total of nine roads that
were made totally impassable by this
storm
and left in a condition which made them
look like an earthquake had struck i've
passed around some photos so you can see
a sampling
seven of those were paved roads an
expensive investment for our little town
of 850 people
three and a half miles of crane brook
road a major north-south paved road of
which the paving was completed only a
few years earlier was severely damaged
and the crane broke a light alongside
the road became a huge water management
and wetlands issue
culvert failures caused massive damage
to the area and we feared more flooding
would happen with future rainstorms
clark's sugar house was surrounded by
debris washed down from the road and in
short it was a natural disaster that
caused extensive and expensive damage
which a small town like acworth would
not be able to absorb
decades of investment in our roads and
bridges were demolished in one night
causing issues concerning safety
commerce the environment and quality of
life
it was clear to people who had come to
actually see the damage that we had
millions of dollars and years of repair
work facing our town
initially the estimates were around 10
to 15 million dollars they have since
gone higher because of inflation and
difficulty obtaining materials
the town had to get temporary work
started immediately to make roads
passable and safe
des and homeland security emergency
management did not come
until september 8 2021 to assess damage
a full month and a half after the floods
hit us
meanwhile state roads that were damaged
around vilas pool and alstead and other
spots on route 123a were being addressed
by state crews nhdot was kind enough to
loan us road barriers and signage to
alert citizens to closed roads
i sent out emails with photos and videos
of the damage and pleaded with our state
leadership including the fiscal
committee and executive council for
financial help
and while i received much sympathy and
concern from my colleagues and from the
house and senate finance leaders i was
surprised and shocked to find out that
there was absolutely no statutory
vehicle in our state statutes to have
immediate financial help available to
any municipality that suffered this kind
of damage from a natural disaster
none
currently our state is flush with arpa
funding and a healthy surplus yet
acworth has not had any financial help
from the state because there's no
statutory vehicle to get it to us we
have since had a town meeting to
authorize a two point one million dollar
loan
from a skelmet bank
who was willing willing to work with us
but we still have to figure out how to
pay it back
our town has enormous financial
challenges facing us
the only statute that touched on the
possibility of state help was rsa 21 p
colon 37. the statute allowed money to
be loaned to a municipality from the
state treasury but only after a
presidential declaration of emergency
was granted by the president of the
united states
that declaration would also allow our
state municipalities to file for fema
funding later on
in the beginning for us that was months
away
it was of zero immediate help to our
town we needed immediate financial help
to pay for material and workers to make
our roads temporarily sound until
permanent fixes can be done with the
help of the fema disaster programs
there was actually one other statute
that could have been used and that was
rsa 9 colon 13d regarding civil
emergencies and that would require the
governor to act to provide funds in a
civil emergency
he chose not to do that despite letters
and requests from my constituents
our letters never even got the courtesy
of a reply
the governor did send a letter to the
president requesting an emergency
declaration on this on september 27 2021
a full two months after the storm hit us
the disaster emergency declaration was
granted one month later on october 28
2021 so it took three months for an
emergency declaration to be declared
in that time period acworth had to
scramble to temporarily fix roads to
make them safe and passable and figure
out how to pay for it with its limited
funds especially as winter was on the
horizon and we all knew the ground would
start freezing by the end of october
it's january now
all of our roads are open and passable
we're just completing a damage inventory
for fema it is unlikely that we will see
any fema money until late spring at best
acworth declared its own state of local
emergency on monday august 9 2021 and
the acworth select board voted to alert
department of revenue that we would be
overspending our budget and let them
know we'd be taking three hundred fifty
thousand dollars out of our fund balance
which at the time had five hundred and
fifty thousand dollars as a balance that
left us with a recommended minimum fund
balance of two hundred thousand dollars
acworth had already spent 150 000 of
that 350 000 on temporary road repairs
for the charlestown road luther hill
road intersection and upper dairy hill
road culvert repair to make them
passable
those roads were of utmost importance so
farmers could stop dumping their milk
because milk trucks could not get
through as well as allowing feed trucks
to come in with feed for dairy cows it
would also allow customers through to el
sessors blueberry farm at the height of
the picking season it was also the roads
necessary for the multi-million dollar
bascom maple farms to get and send
delivery trucks through
making sure these commercial businesses
could get back to work was crucial
given we had already burned through a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars for
one intersection
we are worried now or we were worried
how far the remaining two hundred
thousand dollars would take us to do
other needed temporary road repairs
the town also had to hire an engineer to
assess damage and start working on
damage inventory and materials inventory
it was not an easy or quick task to do
we had to find out how much material
we'd need and time and labor involved
for just the temporary fixes
and then get engineers and contractors
to work with us later on the permanent
fixes
we also had a scramble to obtain des
emergency permits
there were costs associated with
obtaining all of this work there were
miles of roads to assess and on some
roads the damage was quite extensive
in my opinion
our own homeland security emergency
management was ill-equipped to deal with
the kind of damage in our town and their
assessment tools were antiquated it was
laughable that they sent out engineers
with wheel measurers to try to assess
every foot of damaged roadway
when we had miles of it
this was clearly a task that would have
taken years to accomplish and an idea
that was quickly abandoned
so given all that and our experiences it
was my opinion that we had to have a
statute such as this one that i'm
presenting today one which would provide
gap funding to municipalities that have
extensive damage
and that is little resources and a small
tax base to absorb the cost of such
damage
the gap funding would allow towns to
have some financial breathing room
between the time the disaster strikes to
when fema money becomes available
it would go a long way to helping a
small town with little resources to
begin to rebuild and make roads and
other infrastructure safe for its
citizens and businesses
using our fund balance some capital
reserve money and some money from our
muscoma loan to date acworth has spent
about one million two hundred seventeen
thousand one hundred nineteen dollars on
flood and road repairs
and for two
2022 we are budgeting one million eight
hundred sixty two thousand six hundred
forty two for flood repairs alone
our municipal budget is usually around
1.3 million but in 2021 we overspent
because of the flood damage repairs
we're looking at a municipal tax mill
rate increase of from seven dollars and
eighty one cents to nine dollars and
twenty one cent uh twenty seven cents
per ferment per mill for our residents
but we're trying to cut out other areas
of the 2022 budget to bring that
increase down
this bipartisan bill seeks to set up a
municipal disaster relief fund a fund
that would be funded in part by
municipalities themselves through an
annual payment from their town to fund
to the fund which acts like a risk pool
of sorts
money would also be deposited into it by
the state on an annual basis through the
state budgeting process as well as
through any infrastructure grants they
can obtain from the federal government
it may be too late for acworth to
benefit from such a fund but it would
have
it would have been
a godsend
had we had access to that kind of relief
money
so i hope that you'll pass this bill out
of your committee with an otp
recommendation and i'm happy to answer
any questions that you have regarding
this bill or the damage that we
sustained thanks
to the committee does the committee have
any questions for representative aaron
yes representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question my
question pertains to page 1 line 15
of the bill
and specifically um i'm looking at the
0.005 percent
that seems low to me
and
almost there's
as a result of that figure
there's almost no cost to
municipalities
to contribute to this risk management
pool
that provides the gap funding
so for example like in brookline the
0.005
of our budget of 6 million dollars is a
annual contribution to this fund
so my question is is that figure correct
would be
fine
follow follow-up follow-up go ahead i i
believe that there might be a like a a
scribner's error if you will yeah and
that it's it should be 0.5 percent or
0.005
yeah we were we were looking i told the
um
the drafter that it was it should be a
half of one percent
so for example for for acworth it would
have been something like five thousand
dollars
yes representative powell
add one more fault so are you clear that
in the language of the bill there's
there's an error i agree that
half a percent
is
is more reasonable but in here just the
way that it's stated in the language
i i see an error yeah yeah okay thank
you
representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman
uh and thank you for taking uh the
question representative
could you tell me do you eventually get
uh
money uh recovery money from fema or any
other state like this is a
gap
uh bill it gets you over the hump but do
you eventually get the
relief from the federal government or
state government when you have a
disaster such as this
okay so
thank you for your question
so how this is going to work is that as
we've got an inventory of projects that
we're going to do and as we
start a project and work on this project
the town has to lay out that funding
and at the end of when the project is
completed say one stretch of roadway
you submit all the paperwork to fema
citing all the the
expenses for that road repair and if
fema approves they have to approve all
the parts of that
submission
when they approve it they only pay they
pay you back 75
of that expense
and so
the town would have to still
be kicking in 25 percent of that which
there's another senate bill being heard
tomorrow
that um
would have that be 12 and a half
by the town and 12 and a half by the
state that the state would share that 25
so but to your question
um
the town will get 75 of whatever
whatever fema approves
um and then
you know they're still in
they're still
responsible for the 25
which
when we're looking at the millions of
dollars worth of damage to our town 25
percent is still a huge ginormous amount
of money for our town to be able to
absorb
i thank you for you
thank you representative gallagher
so
i um remember
previous floods in the state um in 2005
there was
one in alstead and then 2006 there were
some
in the merrimack river in general i was
wondering if
you could compare and contrast the
floods
in acworth with those as well as how the
recovery efforts
um for them compared
like i mean if we didn't have this fund
in 2005 or 2006 either then how did we
recover from those
thank you for your question
representative gallagher
very good question
i was trying to find that out myself but
from what i understand
most of the damage that was done
that happened
back in that time
were state roads
and the state certainly had
the money to
do the work and recover
a lot of the stretch of road on route to
123 and 123a
were the places where a roadway was
extremely damaged and that was a result
of from lake warren there was a breach
that
happened in uh
some of their culverts up there
so we had this wall of water that just
came down the state the state roadways
and damaged them
in this
flood that happened july 29th in our
town of akworth
we had many
most of the roads that were damaged were
and the damage that the town is now
responsible for were all municipal roads
so that's kind of
why
there was really no need for the towns
back then that i understand
to have sought help from the state in
this manner
thank you representative for taking my
question
um i think it's
certainly a duty of government to
make available this sort of
uh disaster relief so i am a definitely
in favor of generally of this
this is kind of a nitpick uh
but on page one line 25
you say if the amount of the total
damage
is greater than the municipality's
annual municipal
budget
now
do you mean
the annual budget for road and
road repairs
or their entire budget
i was looking at the entire municipal
budget
in our in our town of acworth the
municipal budget usually runs around
1.3 million dollars
the amount of damage that we had
sustained in our town was well over five
on 10 15 million dollars
and so
it's very clear that a small town like
ours
uh
would not be able to absorb this kind of
damage um we could
we had money put away certainly in our
road and bridge funds
uh we had money in our capital reserve
fund certainly none of it um even
touched the amount of money that we
would need
to uh cover the damages follow up mr
chairman yes please go ahead well
i i understand what you're saying
but if the damage
was a significant amount but it did not
equal let's say it came up to 75 of the
municipal budget
then based upon how this is written
unless i'm reading it wrong
that
you wouldn't be able to draw from this
you see what i'm saying i do
so i i just think that that greater than
the municipality's annual municipal
budget
is
kind of limiting
uh in a in a way that would be very
difficult to get any good out of this
well i was also trying to take into you
know factor in
i wanted to put some thresholds on this
certainly
um
and certainly to help specifically those
communities that are really um
don't have the tax base
to to pay for this to absorb this kind
of damage
um
if the committee feels that the
thresholds that i've placed on this bill
are a little you know too high or too
extreme i invite you to
make it
a little bit
more
you know
if you feel it's it should be more
reasonable so to speak
um but i am
i feel that you know the larger
communities the nashua's the
manchester's certainly have the kind of
budget that they could fix their
municipal roads that are damaged like
that
whereas the smaller rural towns really
are the ones that need the help
and um and i recognize too that at some
point you know when there's fema money
coming that that's going to cover 75
percent of that that kind of damage
depending on what they approved to pay
for
so and that's why i i kind of laid it
out that way
but if like i said if the committee
feels that
uh some of these thresholds should be
eased a little bit i'd be happy for that
too
thank you mr chair um
thank you so much for bringing this
forward and i
i do understand that for small towns it
must be difficult i'm i'm out of nashua
so i'm much as you pointed out
where we're kind of we have larger
budgets but my questions to you are um
it references here that it says
manufacture wishing to draw from the
fund in the future shall pay into the
fund i'm sorry this is page 1 line 14.
so i take from that that not all
municipalities it's enabling they don't
have to join it and so on
but if they do how would they opt in and
is there a um
must be in the fund for x number of
years before they can draw out
i haven't stipulated anything any
details for um
how you know that there's a time limit
for you to be
uh in the fund i
i thought that that's some details
perhaps that
homeland security and emergency
management our department of safety
would work out in rules
i
made it so that they would be the ones
administering the fund
but certainly my intention is for um
yes it to be enabling in uh legislation
that if a town wants to
uh join in on on this that they can
um because
for instance um
if it's in my mind so
acworth would pay 5 000 a year into this
fund
or any other small town you know what a
percentage of their municipal budget
because if they were to establish a fund
on their own
and put five thousand dollars for
example away every year it would take
them decades to even
come up with you know a substantial
amount of money whereas if this is a
pooled
kind of risk pool
and the state is also contributing funds
to it that there is going to be a more
substantial pool to draw funds from and
that's kind of
how my my thought was for this are there
any other questions from the committee
mr chairman
could i do if i could ask ask you to
hold your questions i know we have a
representative that's going to need to
lead leave the hearing
for another commitment but so we'll come
back to representative aaron
with your questions
representative edwards would you like to
join representative aaron at the
at the
table and there are
there are
for all of you testifying there are
wipes
on the table so if you want to wipe the
uh thank you mr chairman uh i'm
representative jess edwards representing
auburn chester and sandown
um i i do have another committee meeting
at 9 30 so i appreciate your indulgence
to let me speak now i i am not a subject
matter expert on on this topic uh i
i i have
uh talked a great deal about represe
about the disaster uh out in
representative aaron's district and
and i'm familiar with what happened to
my my hometown or where i grew up the
missouri river
overflowed
uh
totally took out an amazing
park
where i had
had a lot of fun as a as a teenager
and
it took absolutely years and years to
get the federal disaster relief money
and
so so that sort of opened my eyes to how
much pain
the slowness of the process can cause a
local town
and as i was thinking about
representative aaron's issues you know
what if a bridge had been taken out that
kept the population cluster from being
able to get to the local emergency room
you know the the issue there is speed
you gotta you gotta fix some stuff fast
and if you don't have the money you know
no money no mission they like to say
so uh i i support
the creation of this revolving fund
um i
i'm a little leery about the emphasis on
temporary construction versus allowing
it to go ahead and be permanent because
in my experience you know sometimes it
costs 60 percent to do a
temporary job when it would only cost a
hundred percent to do the permanent job
and so it's pennywise pound foolish
sometimes i think to just do temporary
fixes but but i think i think that's
something the committee could think
about
uh this is such an obvious idea i don't
understand why it hasn't been done i
mean we're obviously brilliant
but there have been brilliant people in
the state house before us and i don't
understand why there isn't already a
revolving fund because this is sort of a
blinding flash of the obvious that this
kind of thing is needed
so so why isn't there and so it makes me
wonder
you know if the federal rules get in the
way of
of replenishing a revolving fund is that
is that part of the issue and just
curious you know i i i just cited
nebraska but nebraska doesn't have an
account like this so i just wonder if
there are other states uh where there's
a precedent for this if there are no
other states then maybe there is an
issue with the federal rules
um and then it wasn't clear to me as as
i looked at it and i should have
provided this input to
the sponsor earlier but i i i don't
understand what happens if uh the fund
uh wants to exceed 30 million so you
know what if they're you know we're
flush with cash and the towns keep
wanting to pay in what happens to
the 31st million dollar i don't know
so um so i i really hope the uh
committee with all your expertise
figures uh you you know the smart way to
do this because uh the the need is there
so
um i i'll take questions if there are
i'm seeing no questions i i had a
question or comment from representative
aaron's we've had it was my intention
so may i be excused yes all right thank
you i had a uh
thought that
we this is this is an early bill so i
had a thought that we might
exec this bill this morning
instead of just hearing it but
with the uh
issues that have brought up so far about
the
the uh
the finance number
uh would it would it be
we could i can postpone the exact
portion of this
to give you an opportunity
to make an amendment to
incorporate that change is that a
reasonable thing to do
that would be fine i know um
i mean even if you want to execute and
then i can draw up an amendment so that
it can go the amendment can go to the
finance committee
um
but i i also had a suggestion from
senator gaida
uh that he wanted to
because you know this he's expecting it
to come to the senate as well and
um
he said that uh he would like to see the
effective date uh be
taking effect
upon you know passage
he believes that the uh
let me see he gave me another suggestion
on
um
he believed that the it should be 50 of
the municipal budget
uh
instead of the
on line twenty four page one
um that the municipality may only draw
from the municipal road and bridge
disaster relief fund if the amount of
the total damage is fifty percent of the
municipalities annual municipal budget
so he again he wanted to lower that
threshold as well
so i'd be happy to draft an amendment uh
you know to this
bill
if you want to wait for me to do that
and then exec that's fine if you want to
exec the bill the way it is and then
have me submit changes to finance i'd be
happy to do that as well
okay
yes representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um i share your concern about um
on page one line 24 about having it
exceed the town's municipal budget
but i would actually
um
be curious about your ideas about
striking from
line 22 through line 27 because
it doesn't seem as though
just drawing once a year is relevant if
if you have a major flood
major damage and then eight months later
you have it again
um
but then you're you can't fix those
roads a second time because you've
already drawn from the fund it seems as
though it should just continue
to cover any natural disaster damage
regardless of if it happens in the same
year or not that was roman numeral three
and then getting to your point too
um
you know fixing let's say a two mile
stretch of road for a very small town
like yours
will have a much bigger impact on
um
on your access to that money well
actually it would probably have a bigger
impact on a town with a larger budget
because they have to exceed the
threshold of their total municipal
budget so
i agree
i i don't even know if that's that line
is necessary
um and then one other thing if you can
indulge me
it's not in this bill but one of my
concerns reading it is that if a town
doesn't do proper maintenance on their
roads they may be more susceptible to
damage from a natural disaster
would that be a consideration in
i hadn't really thought of that you know
that's a good point um
certainly a small town is going to
struggle to keep their roads maintained
to begin with i mean in acworth we have
66 miles of road in our small town
and certainly the tax base is not robust
enough to maintain all of those roads
properly
um
we've struggled with that
and and have you know a significant
amount of our budget every year does go
to road maintenance i would venture to
say probably a good
65 to 70 percent of our town municipal
budget is roads
we try best we can to maintain them all
um
some of them we
feel that well you know what let's just
re leave them gravel or dirt roads
rather than paving them because paving
them you have to maintain with
you know top coats and and make sure
that
every the culverts are cleared and all
these other uh activities as municipal
people you should
certainly be aware of that
so i i you know i don't i don't know um
if we can or should put that kind of uh
caveat in there that if
what based on your road maintenance
program or whether your roads are being
maintained properly
um
certainly that could be a contributory
issue when there's uh
a disaster or
storms or floods
uh
one of the other problems that we had
when crane brook road was totally
destroyed a three and a half mile
stretch of road
was that a beaver bam beaver dam broke a
couple of beaver dams broke from one of
the beaver bogs up there
and that contributed to the volume of
water that was coming down that roadway
so
you know do we also include in here you
know your local water management i mean
it's there's a lot of things that
contribute to why these floods cause
these kinds of damage okay thank you
very much sure
representative guthrie thank you mr
chairman thank you again for taking the
question um it seems that from
the comments that
some members of the committee feel that
this is restrictive
uh making it more difficult for you to
get that gap money when you're looking
uh amendment if you put in an amendment
would you look on page two the first uh
eight pages i wonder how quickly
you could get
the funds that you need for the roads if
in fact this passes with the amount of
uh effort you have to put in before you
can get any money particularly the
engineering
uh i don't know how long that takes
just uh does this my question i guess is
to you is is that that area from page
one to nine which really puts what
you have to do before you get any funds
do you feel that that is more
restrictive
uh than you want it and would you look
at that when you make the amendment
uh
you know
when
when the thank you for your question and
to your point when we had all this
damage happen
we quickly got
a town engineer involved to go down
assess the damage see where we needed to
get uh work done quickly so
i
i thought that you know it
occurrence of events of these items to
be
uh be able to be presented fairly
quickly anyway because you're going to
have an engineer take a look at the
roads or even your road crew
and by the way in the town of akworth we
had exactly
three people three four people
employed in our road crew it was the
supervisor or the road the road agent
and i don't know if it was two or three
people who was uh working with him
so obviously we had
you know very small crew
involved in trying to get all these
roads uh
see which roads were out which roads
needed
priority in priority
to see which roads needed to be put back
together as best they could
for emergency vehicle purposes and so
forth so we had you know an assessment
report uh that was prepared by our road
engineer
outlining what the temporary repairs
were going to be
which roads needed work quickly
that was almost done
you know within a week or two
and then uh to to send a letter to the
commissioner of the department of safety
and director of division of homeland
security
uh requesting the amount needed to
you know that you could be able to tell
them we need
five hundred thousand dollars right now
to fix this
and um
in a demonstration that the roads are
bridges due to natural damaged uh were
of critical importance obviously you
know if you have roads that
uh are not passable and you have to have
emergency vehicles to get through them
that's going to be
you know you'd be able to demonstrate
that pretty quickly so
you know i think that the uh funds would
be able to be disbursed to a town fairly
quickly once they know what the damages
that they're dealing with thank you very
much for you thank you mr chairman mr
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um i have a concern with regard to a
term on page two line one
and that is the um
reference to a certified road engineer
so within within civil engineering
road engineers in bridge engineers are
different areas of specialty
so my concern is um
that's very specific road engineer and
in the line two it also goes on to say
that this certified road engineer will
um
be assessing damage to roads and bridges
so my question is do you agree that
perhaps it would might be better
to
cite a professional engineer
because that would
that that would imply
a professionally licensed
civil engineer and that that would be
more
comprehensive
in terms of
assessing roads and bridges sure that's
more questions yes representative clean
thank you mr chairman and um
my question goes on to what i had
originally um
spoke about about the uh how they would
how municipalities would opt in
um i i do have a concern while i think
this is a great
fund i think it's it really is a good
idea my concern is that can
municipalities be able to opt in and opt
i i guess it's kind of like we only want
insurance when we get to a point where
we're going to need insurance
would it be better to um
and i say this in reading the the last
page where it says that the new
hampshire municipality association
indicates that if every municipality in
the state did it it would be eight
million dollars in annual revenue but
would it not be better to
almost say that municipalities with a
budget an annual budget less than
x amount of dollars because we know that
they would have a hard time
um
kind of compelling those not making it
so much enabling um i guess i'm just i'm
just concerned that municipalities are
going to come in and out and in and out
of this fund as as they feel that their
budget would warrant it thank you for
your question and that that's a good
point i
i kind of thought of this in the same
way as we have our um
what's it called
for the for the
road
it's a road mutual aid
association throughout the
[Music]
from the d.o.t
they have um
i forget the name of it but it's it's a
it's a fund that
it's not a fund but it is if you need um
signage
or
um barriers or some sort of thing it's
it's a mutual aid that you can go
you have to join it
uh it's sort of like i think fifty
dollars a year that they charge
municipalities to be a part of this
mutual aid association
and um
when we found it
when we found out that you know we
needed
road signage and that kind of thing and
that could not be
um given to us by department of
transportation for whatever reason they
were they were busy off doing all their
repairs too
but uh this mutual aid association
is
uh available if you pay into it
now they don't
they will allow you to pay into it even
after the damage happened last week
so that you can access a
list of names and so forth of contacts
to other towns who could help you out if
you needed sand or
signage or something
and so that's what i was kind of
thinking when i when i put that wording
in here
but certainly
with the
the rulemaking that homeland security
emergency management could come up with
this
you know if they
we could probably make some tweaks to
that
thank you very much i mean yeah i
absolutely understand that you know you
don't want to buy insurance just when
you need it you have to have that in
place thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh
i have uh
a question about the uh
page page 2 line 16
where uh you're going to be adopting
interim rules
uh there's no mention of when final
rules would be required
i think interim rules are fine but uh
you probably don't want to live 30 years
with interim rules
so
when if you're making a uh amendment i
would suggest this is not a question is
it would you
agree that probably
uh
requiring final rules is a good idea
yes
okay uh
we uh we have a couple more people to
testify but just so i don't lose track
here representative aaron's i've i've
made
notes that this might need four
amendments okay
the the language about engineers
and also about
rules
so i so that's those are the four so far
that i have
um
and
with that many changes i'm reluctant to
pass it with
those defects in it
uh hoping someone else will make this
change so what i would be looking for is
could you
put an amendment in to capture those
four things
and have it back to us by friday oh
absolutely
uh you know barring any kind of problem
uh with
the workload in drafting but certainly i
will put something together today and
and send it back to them okay i'd like
to get a uh i see your hand
representative power but i'd like to get
a couple more people
up in front of the microphone we're
going to be getting out of time if you
can
hold that and maybe wrap it into a
question for the next person to come up
unless it's something real quick
thank you mr chair it is real quick with
regard to your list
for the um possible amendment
did you forget um a correction of that
percentage
because that's how i put dollar amount
yeah okay thank you
uh okay let's uh let's move forward and
uh ask representative
take the microphone
thank you representative thank you very
much and i appreciate all your time and
looking at this and
helping me refine this to be a better
bill i mean
this was really totally new territory
for me
but i just know that our towns are small
towns especially
in a disaster such as this
really and truly do need assistance from
the state when something like this
happens so
thank you very very much for your
attention on it
the floor is usa representative thank
you mr chairman members of the committee
representative ken weiler
rockingham 13 the towns of hampstead and
kingston
uh it's difficult to plan for disasters
past experience has shown that very few
of them happened as expected the
disruption of the infrastructure caused
by disasters has had too many delays
many of the delays deal with who can
begin mitigation and how will that
entity be paid
by establishing a fund that can be used
immediately to begin restoration efforts
we can hope to improve response times
and minimize
disruptions
i believe the funds are available to
begin funding this proposal and the
municipal contributions envisioned will
maintain it for the long run
if we do not begin mitigation
immediately the damage is sure to become
worse than when it first discovered
homeland security and emergency
management would be the obvious place
for this fund to be managed and the
place for the most expertise to be found
i hope that you will support the bill
thank you i also noticed when i was
going over it last night
that .005
percent
um
and also the
the talk a municipal budget
my town has a municipal budget total
budget of like say 20 million
15 million of it goes to the schools
five
four five six million goes to run the
town and another million goes to the
county so which piece are we
putting this stipend on are we putting
it on the 20 million or the 5 million
that's really in fact the municipal
budget so i don't know if we need
tweaking to say what a municipal budget
is
and even then
.005
um
if it was
.005 times the budget it's like 5 000
for every million
i believe
we recognize the fact that there's okay
decimal point error probably in there
yeah and we'll be looking at it again if
it gets to finance to just to figure out
how much money would and i see that uh
municipal association thinks 8 million
dollars a year would come in and i i can
probably believe that depending on what
part of the budget you're really
multiplying this figure by them whether
using .005
times the budget of 0.005
which is
100 times less so anyway
there's there's those few things that
that i'm
happy that the committee
found right away
and uh you know i
i've been doing this for 30 plus years
and i've seen about every 10 or 15 years
as a disaster
and
it's always
never repeated the same way and
sometimes it's a river sometimes it's a
just overall flooding but it's it's
never the same event and it's always
unexpected so
yes we need to be better prepared for
this thank you would you be willing to
take any questions i would be happy to
anyone have a question for
seeing none thank you so much for your
testimony
thank you next we'd like to hear from
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee walt stapleton claremont ward
3 sullivan county district 5.
i was going to i am in support of 1665
[Music]
and i was going to speak more in general
terms but i'm going to forego
general remarks
for the interest of time
but it occurred to me that
there might be a possibility instead of
0.5
maybe an indexed
scale
and i say that because in claremont we
resources like acworth or
plainfield or other towns
and our budget is much more than the 1
million that was cited for acworth
so you know when you have a budget of
10 or 20 million dollars
for a larger municipality
now you're beginning to impact
the budget for that particular item
and
you know like buying insurance because
in a way it is kind of an insurance is
an option to have help in the case of an
emergency perhaps an indexed or scaled
percentage relative to municipal budgets
and and maybe even
the
geological nature of the town if you
have no water courses except a swamp or
two
your need for the disaster relief
will be much less than several streams
brooks and so forth running through
towns
so that would be my recommendation as
long as there's going to be a
an amendment made maybe consider that as
an option
um
the impacts are going to continue
for
flash floods and heavy rains almost
tropical rains in claremont we had some
war shouts we have a large enough budget
we have a large enough
resource of dpw to handle these things
and the budget will handle supplement
by contractors
but we have noticed that there's been a
change
wider culverts better ditching
a larger rip-rap because we're going to
have more of this
and we believe that our surrounding
communities the smaller towns need this
kind of assistance
because they don't have the wherewithal
and the resources of the larger
municipality so i'm going to end with
that and ask you to support
1665 especially if it comes forward with
an amendment
would you be willing to take questions
from the committee representative yes
anybody have questions for
representative stapleton
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
and last on
my list of pink cards here is uh
uh
testimony from uh natch grayas
thank you nate graves for the new
hampshire municipal association we
support this bill the way we read it is
it's an opt-in provision i know that was
a question that came up earlier
and
i guess the only thing i would add
not to be repetitive but i believe the
committee's pretty much identified this
is the bill as written is really
designed for smaller municipalities to
have access to funds when they have a
major natural disaster go through their
area
and as the committee identified you know
if we adjust the
line 25 for the total damage amount
maybe to be something like the
municipality's annual road budget
or if it's some other calculation that
may attract more municipalities to
choose to participate in the fund
the only other thing that i would add
is that uh
from our reading essentially over time
the state would contribute 30 million
dollars to this
fund it would
that's the that's the cap on the state
funding at this point in time and then
municipalities would
annually contribute so
assuming no natural disasters happen the
fund would continue to accumulate monies
and there's no there's no cap on that it
would just continue to accumulate monies
um and then as natural disasters
occurred it would pay out
um for that which would be the reduction
in the fund i'm happy to take questions
are you willing to accept questions from
the committee yes
are there any questions for the nhma yes
representative klee
thank you again mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh it kind of
relates back to what i had said before
and i think you touched on it when you
said that
those those smaller towns and so on so
would it not be better to
look at towns that have a a budget of
whether
an annual municipal budget of
less than x amount of millions or
whatever it would be
because they would be the ones that
would be benefiting more for it than
i can't choose among towns i represent
all of them um so that's a policy
decision for the committee thank you so
much representative power thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh my question pertains to the
fiscal note
where it says that um
there would be a need for a part-time
planner with an annual salary of 30 000
um
dollars in order to administer
the program so my question is um
where in this bill
and or how
would this
position be
authorized and how would it from
what department would support
the salary
i i would defer to the department of
safety for that i i don't
i don't know what their requirements are
okay um at this point uh representative
aaron what we're going to do is i was
inclined to execute this bill this
morning
but i'm not going to do that i'm going
to wait for
the various amendments that was spoken
of and look to try to get those by the
end of the week
and uh and when when i get them then
i'll i'll put this in the ex and the
list to be exact
okay that
concludes the
hearing on
on
and for those of you expecting an
executive session on that bill
today we're not going to have it i'm not
ready
that's the ranking member did you want
to have a short
conversation could we mr chair sure okay
i'm gonna take a recess recess for five
minutes
um
oh
okay
hey
um
no
yes
she wants copies
yeah you know what you do you could see
could you go see heather in there
good
okay
yep
can heather take care of that no
some of these may have flipped a little
bit
let me make sure
11 12.
okay so but we're gonna i'm gonna let
brilliant
um thank you mr chair is this opening a
discussion yes only
it was in gallagher okay
um i think it seems like a pretty simple
fix so
let's pass it
okay
thank you any other
comments yes
thank you mr chair um i would agree with
representative gallagher in in my
understanding as this is a housekeeping
um
bill
due to the fact that it was signed by
the governor on may 17 2021
and it just fixes language that was an
oversight and it enables
that the city council
shall also have the power to remove as
they have the power to remove any police
commissioner as they um
in the bill that was signed they were
given the power to
appoint
okay any other uh
comments
or questions about uh
and uh we're just
soon going to take a vote on this so uh
think about it if you if you're okay the
way it is or you want to make changes
okay
we looking for a motion
to uh
ot pill otp
yes representative power
thank you mr chair i would like to make
a motion ought to pass on house bill
mr chairman yes
uh we have a couple of seconds so
mr secretary you pick one
all right the uh
the motion's been made and been
seconded is there any last discussion on
this
hey uh mr
okay we'll call vote on hb 1029 ought to
pass
represent pmit yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp yes
representative guthrie yeah
representative yes
representative here
representative power yes
um reps of majority
yes representative long
yes
representative gilman yes
representative tyloski yes
yes vann
representative clee
yes
representative gallagher
unless there are any objections i'm
going to uh
okay that concludes our business on
hb 1029
next we're going to
look at
hb 1046
mr chair i move
ought to pass on house bill 1046.
okay
the emotions been made to
the itl and the motion's been seconded
oh i'm sorry did you say otp i did oh
okay the motion's been made to otp and
mr chairman yes
um
correct me if i'm wrong but uh
house bill 1046
there's a
another bill that we are going to
pick up
that could
uh
is more general
yes
noted
okay that's just my opinion
any other comments yes and thank you mr
chair and thank you representative um
and i was
curious rather than to
um
i was curious based on what we might
receive as a motion or as an amendment
to a further to an additional bill
about whether or not we should act on
this as it is because without that
amendment i think this bill would have
been important to move forward on or
could have been significant to move
forward on uh if the full committee
feels that that is inappropriate we can
take action and then uh additional
action after that
so but uh i i felt as it is and without
any additional amendments to any other
bills that the motion should be ought to
pass all right let me make a suggestion
i hear i hear what you're saying and i
don't disagree with it i would
suggest that we move forward with the
and
pass it or itl it
and then
when we consider 1397 based on how that
vote turns out we can come back and we
can reconsider
fine with me okay
i serve at the pleasure of the chair is
okay
so the motion
is to otp
as as presented
and mr clark would you take the role
please
clerk votes no uh representative tripp
i vote no
representative guthrie
representative los alas down
representative notter no
representative melvin no
representative no
representative power no
representative missouri
yes
yes thank you uh representative
representative gilman yes representative
chowski
yes
representative perez
uh representative klee
yes
representative gallagher
representative run yes
okay that motion fails is it is there
is that is that really rich yes it is
emotions been made to itl is there a
second
representing melbourne second
all right motion's been made and
seconded is there any further discussion
yes
um i didn't get to speak to the otp
motion but i i would like to say that i
think it's been the tradition in new
hampshire and the u.s that we elect
the people that elect are those cons are
the constituents of who they're electing
as in sullivan county there are going to
be people voting for a commissioner
that's not going to represent them
that's all i want to say i think people
should vote for someone that they're
good that's going to represent them not
for someone who's going to represent
somebody else
okay mr clerk would you take a roll
please
oh i'm sorry
it wasn't more
comments no
okay take a roll please
okay itl on house bill 1046. um
representative pmrt
yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp
representative guthrie
representative los alas yes
representative notter
representative melvin
yes
representative
uh representative power
and representative mijori
i'm sorry representative my vote is no
no no switch over here then
no
representative
of the record representative cleveland
no no
okay
uh representative gallagher
no
representative running no
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes 10 to 9
mr chair yes just
just procedurally then um
we didn't i uh we put the first bill on
the consent calendar this bill as it
stands right now
would probably need a committee report
is it fair to say we should wait until
we do 1397 before we assign a committee
port a committee report in favor or
against
no i think that's you have a good point
i think we should have signed a
so
the motion was
was otp
ital
we have
representative
trip are you going to make the
do the
diane
power representative power
okay make sure i'm at the right spot
here
okay
for the time being closes our business
the next bill we're going to consider
is hb
which is relative to competitive bidding
and a second
representative power second
discussion
um
could
so wait sorry i didn't quite catch what
was the motion again
um could someone making the itl motions
speak to why
this is uh this is one of those things
where uh my notes on this bill are the
uh
right off to the beginning is i wrote
down is there a problem and uh
nothing in the testimony that was heard
convinced me there was a problem this is
one of those things where uh uh
create
a process where uh
it would be replacing processes that
already exist in the counties so this is
why i
determined it's uh not not
ready to uh
legislate
representative
yes the the thing that struck me on this
bill
is that
if you require a competitive bidding
process
municipalities that are very small do
not have the staff
to
actually conduct this
so it would be a
a major burden for a small municipality
to
accomplish this
so from my standpoint that really struck
me
and
i agree with the itl motion
thank you
representative uh gilman
uh
we uh we moved pretty quickly
through this uh
this motion and i i understand
that you had a different motion that you
were going to make
if you had the opportunity out of
courtesy to you i'd i'll give you some
time to explain what your motion would
have been and how how you would have
liked to see the committee vote thank
you mr chair it's
my my motion would have been ought to
pass uh
and as i said in testimony this is
really a house cleaning bill
um right now under
counties and
competitive bidding
uh there are two separate
uh rsas for hillsboro i think or
merrimack and rockingham county this
language is taken directly from one of
those
one of those sub sections
and
so why do we have two subjects
subsections that say the exact same
thing
and white and
and then rockingham has the exact same
amount
i don't i think that
with competitive bidding
it can be done
even in small towns because there are
uh
forms you can you know take off from any
other town such as the ones that have
this already
um and it's um
do we have to make these carveds for
when they when there's opportunities of
advertising that are free
nhma does it other
and then there are even larger ones i
don't see
i don't see the problem with the number
of personnel it takes to write an rfp
thank you representative
yes representative
um thank you mr chair yeah i i support
this bill and i'm against the itl
for the reasons that representative
gilman stated but also it gives
taxpayers the confidence of knowing that
purchases above five thousand dollars
are going to be handled consistently and
responsibly
um to to representative lasalle's point
i
i read this it applies to counties not
small
towns so thank you
yes representative thank you mr chair um
my my thought on this similar to what i
have heard here but then to the comment
about what problem is it is it aiming to
fix and what we saw is the piecemeal
approach to
different uh different counties in the
state
and my hope with this bill and why i
would support it would be to get to some
consistency treat like things alike even
though i respect the fact that each of
the counties is different but a process
should be consistent um so that there is
some expectation uh going in that you
have that consistency and you don't have
to look in different places for
different rules so i would uh so i'm
opposed to the itl and would support a
different motion should we get there
thank you thank you representative
any other comments yes representative
gallagher
yes i
oppose the motion to itl because i
remember
itlling
a similar bill
last year that would have been just for
carroll county and we i believe we did
so on the grounds that we thought it
ought to be for
all counties so
now that we have a bill to do so for all
counties we ought to remain consistent
with
our previous reasoning
and use that here to
thank you
any further comments or questions
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to take a
roll on
hb 11 12.
okay the motionist itl uh hb1112
representative p monty
yes
click votes yes representative tripp i
vote yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas
yes
representative notter yes
representative melvin
representative yes
representative power yes
representative majori no
representative long no
representative gilman no
representative tolsky no
representative perez
no
for the record representative gallagher
says no okay and representative wrong no
and chairman dolan yes
minority majority
president of the uh representative
tripp
you're going to write the
yes i will uh i also have a observation
to share
it appears that if too many of the
microphones are on
then
it
you can't turn
additional microphones on instead of
going red they blink green so uh i would
ask that
if you're not speaking that you turn
your microphone off thank you for that
do we uh
representative powell were you gonna uh
write the uh
some comments on this or just uh
representative thank you mr chair i
believe it was um representative tripp
that was going to do that
if uh representative power is
volunteering now let her do it no i'll
do it
representative maturity do you have a
someone to write the minority i believe
representative gilman is going to write
that
that concludes our business on represe
on
hb 11 12.
next is
hb
relative to municipal representation on
do i have a motion on representative yes
representative tripp
i uh move itl on uh
house bill 1275. is there a second
representative
seconds high second to motion for ito
thank you
uh is there any discussion
yes representative lasallus
i represent the town of litchfield
and
this would be
detrimental if i was to
to
vote otp on this
i would not be representing my
constituents
hi um
i
i support this bill and thus oppose the
motion to itl it because i think
that representation should be
based on population that more people
should mean more representation
so
thus i
uh support i support this bill and
oppose the motion to yell it okay thank
you yes representative
i support the itl for the same reasons
representative lasalles does
it dilutes the vote of communities such
as merrimack and the national regional
planning commission
also as i stated during or asked during
the public hearing i'm not convinced
that
decisions made by larger cities
won't have an effect on smaller towns
and i think they need to have a stronger
voice in making those decisions
representative power
thank you mr chair i also support the
motion
and expedient to legislate
simply due to the fact that this bill as
written increases the influence of large
towns and municipalities at the expense
yes representative
yeah i support that emotion to itl for
the some reason
um i represent a small town and i
believe um i if i support this bill i
going against my constituents
thank you representative clee
uh thank you mr chair um
i i too am gonna support the itl even
though i'm from a large municipality um
and that was based on speaking with um
our city planner and so on and he felt
that
our particular
district and so on was represented well
enough and that it would just add too
many more people to it so thank you
thank you
seeing no further comments i asked the
at 12.75 okay uh
motion is itl and bill 1275.
represent pia monty yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp
i vote yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas yes
representative nada yes
representative melvin yes representative
yes
representative power yes
represent missouri
yes
representative gilman yes
representative chelsea
yes
representative perez
representative
representative klee
yes
representative gallagher
no
representative wrong
yes
the next bill we're going to
yes representative
um so
it remind me the threshold for consent
calendar again are there going to be
committee reports for that or um
yes we have to write a committee report
for for all everything that passes or
fails to pass
that was that's a little different in
so who do we have uh on the hook for
1275 to write the
blurb
i believe that would be me
okay
is there a minority report coming
yes mr chair we'll have a minority
report and we'll decide in just before
the end of the meeting who will be doing
that report unless somebody wants to
jump off eric
[Laughter]
representative gallagher um yeah i'll do
the i'll do the minority report on that
okay the next the next bill we're going
to exec is bill 1387
and this is uh and would enable
municipalities to adopt a property tax
yes
mr or rather representative lasella
yes mr chairman i would like to uh
move
um
inexpedient to legislate on
1387.
is there a second
i'll second that has been made and
seconded
we have any discussion
mr chairman yes
uh
to me the the sponsor of the bill
made
enthusiastic
and i applaud the
the idea
of
improving home ownership particularly
for people who
have trouble affording it
the problem with the bill as i see it
is a homestead exemption
is
it's very complicated and convoluted the
way it's written in my opinion
and secondly anytime you give people an
exemption
how well-meaning
the effort is
someone has to pay the bill for that
and i think that a homestead exemption
would
put up a
significant burden
on
people who did not get the homestead
exemption
thank you those of you
not engaging the committee right now if
you turn your microphones off i
appreciate it
yes representatively
thank you mr chair um
i agree
with my colleague representative los
alas
i i went i went through and i know this
is a um
an enabling bill which means that it's
not going to force anybody to do it but
i think adding one more type of
exemption and so on it's just going to
muddy the waters
i i literally went through all of the
ones at dra and we have so many of the
exemptions i think this is not a bad
idea
i just think we it would be better to do
a whole housekeeping and i know some
people will tell me baby steps baby
steps but
i i look at all the exemptions and this
could actually add to some of the ones
that nashua had if in fact we did um
enable it um and i i just think it it
just kind of muddies the waters but um
i do i do see it as not a bad
bill just not on top of all the ones we
have so thank you representative yes
representative
uh one of the qualifying factors in in
this bill for getting the exemption is
that your
your household
income in the municipality
and
i asked how you would determine this
what the median
household income was and uh the response
was that uh well you just do a google
search and uh
i
i think that's a
innovative idea
but uh i don't believe that
something is subjective as that should
be
determined
be used to determine who is and who
isn't
qualified for this exemption this is why
i support itl
thank you representative gilman
thank you mr chair um i also support the
itl
motion um because
basically because of the reasons that
have already been spoken but um i don't
think it will have the uh
result that the sponsor was looking for
um
as i read it
anybody
can work for this
exemption no matter what age they are
and we're having a problem i understand
being welcoming to people of a younger
age but but this makes it welcoming to
people an older age and her goal was to
get
you know affordable housing for people
of a younger age and i don't think that
happens in this bill
thank you mr chair okay thank you
representative ivy band
now everyone calls me ivy uh i actually
am going to oppose the itl bill for two
reasons one of which is
i do think that
since this is an enabling legislation
any town that or city who chose to use
it would have to look at all of their
existing exemptions and see which ones
they want to retain
in addition to the homestead bill the
second reason is that this
[Music]
a homestead exemption privileges people
who live and work in a community
because it has to be your primary place
and i think those are exactly the people
that we want to retain in the state of
new hampshire and there's no question
that our existing property tax system
makes it very difficult for people to
become homeowners and while i do not
believe that becoming a homeowner
automatically makes you a better person
i think renters are people too
renters also pay
and
i think that it's time to take a hard
look at the way we raise taxes in new
hampshire and i think this is
a great step forward and particularly
since it is
enabling legislation so i'm going to
oppose the motion of itl thank you thank
you any other
representative
hi um yeah i agree with the
representative fan um i support this
bill and
post the motion to itl on the simple
grounds that it makes our tax structure
more progressively structured i believe
that
people with less ability to pay should
pay less in taxes and people with more
ability to pay and pay more in taxes and
it seems like
this bill
uh
fits with that principle so i'm going to
support it and oppose the motion to ito
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair um
i i
think i heard it said initially that if
the intent is very good and i agree with
that completely and i agree with what i
just heard from representative van
representative gallagher about the
intent the problem way to fix the
problem i just don't see all of the
solutions contained in this bill
um that would enable a community to be
able to be confident that they were
doing
uh they were crossing all the eyes
crossing all the t's and dotting all the
i's so i'm not opposed to the intent of
what they were trying to do i just don't
think this bill
gets there so there i just can't i just
can't see how we could pass this one as
it is thank you thank you any further
comments
yes representative
thank you mr chair i also support the
itl uh for a couple reasons one and
although i
typically support enabling legislations
i think people in the community are the
best judge of what's best for them
but this
a decision made by one community can
have impact on neighboring communities
that may have not adopted it
i'd also like to see more study as to
the impact on business decisions where
business would relocate
something like this i think really needs
to be studied at a greater depth and
you know perhaps looked at what would
happen on a statewide level rather than
municipality by municipality thank you
thank you i too uh
liked the idea
however
as i
went through the bill and heard the
presentation from the sponsor
i i cannot overcome
what i believe the
deficiencies in the bill
and therefore
i'm going to support the itl
okay
mr clerk would you take a role please on
1387.
okay the emotion is itl bill 1387.
representative pmrt
yes
collect votes yes representative tripp
representative guthrie
representative los alamos yes
representative
yes
representative melvin
representative here yes
representative power yes
represent majority
yes
representative long yes
representative gilman yes
uh representative chelsea yes
representative perez
representative klee
yes
representative gallagher
no
representative wrong
motion passes
no 16
16 0 yeah one two
three 17
okay 17 to two 17's at two i'm telling
you
we're gonna have the right names in
there
let me see what we got here
is there would there be any objection to
to moving this to the consent
calendar yes there would be
i i object to it
it only takes one
your prerogative
and mr chair i would just uh uh confer
with representative gallagher and
representative van about if either one
of them would like to write the report
okay
i'd like to take yes representative
i'd be happy to write the majority
report
all right i'm going to take a recess for
five minutes stretch your legs and use
the restrooms if you need to
please be back here
at uh by that clock
uh
okay
yes mr chair thank you i'd like to
ought to pass amendment number
2022-0120h
mr chairman
mr chair i can give a summary of the
changes
those of you will remember the original
bill that came before us
earlier
spoke of
changing the length of term for county
officers specifically county attorney
county treasurer county sheriff county
register of deeds
from a two-year term to a four-year term
that would apply to rockingham county
during discussion during the public
hearing
uh there was the the subject brought up
about extending this to all counties
like i know rockingham county is special
but
is it so special that those county
officers need four-year terms when other
counties don't so um this this amendment
extends that and changes language in uh
relevant sections of the rsas to reflect
a four-year term for for those
four
thank you mr chairman being from
hillsborough county
all i can think of is last term we had
the most incompetent
county attorney
and we were so glad that it was only a
mr chair just going back to the
testimony that we heard i
certainly appreciate that you may not
always get the the best person in that
position but not speaking specifically
to that point but the point that what
their case load and workload is going to
be and the fact that many of those
cases issues take more than two years to
resolve that was the point that they
captured me is that they they need more
than two years in order to see
to the end a certain issue
and that's the reason why i i support
this but i i do respect that you could
have somebody in there
who you know that that's the that's the
problem with elections sometimes as we
don't always get you know
exactly so thank you no i'm not looking
i think also the the testimony that
struck me
was the sheriff
who
was a two-year term
and he would he would
be standing at the pole and if he was
elected then he had to go right out and
start campaigning for the next two-year
term so to me the four-year term
thank you
i think what we're doing here is
targeting
mostly full-time employees
of the county
and
those
who are part-time employees like those
those of us sitting around the table
here
we do
we would be stay in the
every two year election but we have a
the
example is brought up about the sheriff
we want this we want the sheriff
out
keeping the peace
arresting people need to be arrested
putting people in jail that need be put
in jail
and so forth same thing with the
county attorney we would hope that
county attorney would be spending
looking at
convictions and
uh
bringing uh bringing actions against
those people that need it
as opposed to
uh for example the county for a sheriff
to be standing on the corner
with a couple of cardboard signs
working as a sheriff as opposed to
working as a candidate
so uh
that's those are my comments
i i and i would uh
i think this
generally general support for this
across
uh both both aisles
and um
so i think we we would make a
a strong statement
if
this passed
unanimously
yes representative wrong yeah i'd also
like to say that since we had the public
hearing i've heard from other county
attorneys who support this amendment
i also ran it by the
my county hillsborough county
commissioner the chair
ms pappas who also
supports it
and to get to mrs notter's point about
or representative notter's point
even the current county attorney is
under
more supervision from the attorney
general's office
it seems like it's a structural issue in
that office and that
having only two years and then having a
change of leadership is very disruptive
on the state level to be able to go in
and provide support for counties so
thank thank you all everyone in advance
for your support
okay are there any more comments yes i
am
can you explain
the difference between the language
oh i'm sorry
representative can you explain the
language in
the amendment
and why it is different other than i see
the rockingham county on on the bill
itself but
um
i'm just a little bit confused with the
language in both cases
you know for example line line
that's compared to that's talking about
the county attorney
and then um elected for four years on
line 17
it talks about all the other offices
then we get down to the end of this i
believe this one talks about the
um
doesn't talk about at all counties
can you you point out where it says all
counties on here for me
just so i can catch it um
my understanding from talking to the
drafting attorney is that
there's separations in the amendment
as they are in the um the actual bill
because of where the occurrence of
vacancies is
mentioned in the rsa so each rsa that
addresses a vacancy
for instance in rsa 7 colon 33 it's
specific to county attorneys and their
length of term
so the amendment has to address not only
that but other occurrences in the rsas
where
terms are mentioned
the
if you look down on the amendment on
line 15 it says amend rsa 653
so that's
one that addresses
beginning you know like specifying
beginning at the 2020 state general
election it would begin
um
in all counties yes yes so in each
county you would consider that
all counties
for those people okay very good come on
any further yes uh representatively
uh thank you uh mr chair and
and um
kind of keying off of what uh rep
representative piemonte said um
the fact that it says an act relative to
the length of terms for county officers
where the original one said rockingham
that's the clarification of that it's
all counties and not just rockingham
county
do i have that correct
yes it's all counties the um
when representative piemonte noted on
line 21 or 22 the reference to
hillsborough county by including all
counties including hillsborough county
they have a specified way of filling
vacancies that may not be consistent
with other counties
someday maybe we can make that
consistent but for the purpose of this
amendment it just extend it to all
counties
thank you very much
representing a trip
uh
i was just gonna make a comment that uh
the original bill was for rockingham
only and uh representative wrong's
okay is there any further comment
on this bill
the amendment i believe the emotion i
all right so we have a motion
to uh
to otp the amendment and it's been
seconded
mr clerk would you take a role
yes sir uh this amendment is number
2022-01208
uh representative pmrt
yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp yes
representative guthrie
representative los alamos yes
representative
yes
representative melvin
representative
representative power yes
majority
yes
representative long yes
representative gilman yes
representative tyloski yes
representative perez
yes
representative
representative klee
yes
representative gallagher
representative wrong
yes
and chairman dolan yes
19-0 passes
without an objection i will uh place
so the amendment passed
19 to zero so now
uh we need to look at
the amendment rather than the bill as
amended
mr chairman
um thank you me um i would like to make
an ought to pass motion on house bill
1397 as amended thank you
is there a second
seeing none uh ask the clerk to take the
okay uh hb 1397 is amended uh
representative pmrt
yes clerk votes yes
representative tripp yes representative
guthrie
representative los alas yes
uh representative
yes
representative melvin
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative
yes
representative gilman
uh represent majority yes
representative
yes
representative perez yes
represent
yes
representative clee
yes representative gallagher
yes representative ryan yes
19-0 motion passes
thank you and without objection i'll
excuse me mr chairman
um earlier i was i had another amendment
for bill will exec at a later date i
would just um request the members to
keep a copy of that for our future
executive session
it was an amendment on house bill 1069
okay i would ask that you give a copy to
secretary
heather goalie outside yeah that she can
keep him at that
administrative one okay thank you
okay we have we're getting near the end
we have one more bill
to exec
it's bill hb
and it's the bill about cyber security
incidents
is there a motion
i move otp on house bill 1277.
i'll second that
okay motion's been made in second and
the only it
mr chairman
the only
and and i could be totally off base on
this where where it says shall
immediately report such incident
and i'm
wondering if the word immediately
you know what does that mean i mean if
it happens at 4 30 on a
on a friday afternoon
you know
um
it just seems kind of
you know it's it's not precise enough
for me but i don't know
i don't have any
substitution for it but does anyone else
have that an issue with the word
immediately
yes
thank you mr chair i have no objection
to the word immediately because you want
to act on these things quickly the state
needs to know as soon as possible in
order to have the least amount of damage
done to whatever trickery is going on
so i have no problem with that word
i t is typically 24 7.
representative vann
yeah i was going to say that usually i t
responses are in fact 24 7. and if it
happens at 4 30 on friday afternoon i
think that's a really good argument for
immediately
so that you can start the damage control
representative piemonte
um i i uh
i had a i'm sorry
i had a conversation with the
commissioner on this and
the way it's written now uh some of
these uh
uh things that will happen in i.t will
you know they'll delay
he's and and one of the examples i did
you hear it on the news before it was
actually reported
uh to the
um department even with the 24-7 what
this does bill does it enhances
that so there is no
lag time
in the uh
in the reporting of it
so
that's all i have to say yes
representative klee
uh uh thank you miss um mr chairman and
um i agree with my colleagues before
that but at the same time i i do agree i
had a little bit of immediate kind of
made me a little bit anxious about it
but i do agree with what everybody said
here i think we need to put something at
this in place so that all parties are
notified as quickly as possible so we
can mitigate any worsening of that
particular situation because it can
happen fast like a wildfire so
thank you
any additional comments
on the bill
oh yes representative
i thank my colleagues for giving me a
warm and fuzzy feeling in my stomach
i believe that
the drafting attorneys would have
considered
that language that's somewhat ambiguous
and
it passed their test and i guess that's
about
as good a legal argument that we can
we can rest on
okay are there any last comments
see now we have a
motion and a second
mr clark would you
call the roll
okay i ought to pass on hb one two seven
seven
uh representative p monty
yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp yes
representative guthrie
representative osiles yes
representative
yes
uh representative melvin yes
representative here
representative power yes
representative mijori yes
representative long yes
representative gilman yes
uh representative chelsea yes
representative perez yes
representative
yes representative klee
yes representative gallagher
yes
representative yes
and chairman dolan yes
uh moshe's passion is 19-0
great thank you
uh without objection i'll place this on
seeing no objection
i'd like to thank uh those substitutes
that came in
to help support the committee and for
donating your time
uh and uh and
allowing us to
access your brain power
to make these things better
as we as we take them one at a time so
uh
and uh
i would say watch watch your
your calendars for the next
round of bills that will be coming out
and you'll stay current
okay with with that
that concludes our
you